okay thank you very much in a few
moments I'll be signing an executive
order imposing hard-hitting sanctions on
the Supreme Leader of Iran and the
office of the Supreme Leader of Iran and
many others
today's action follows a series of
aggressive behaviors by the Iranian
regime in recent weeks including
shooting down of us loans they got the
loan the drill is I guess everyone there
saw that one and many other things
they've done many other things aside
from the individual drone you saw the
tankers and we know of other things that
were done also which were not good and
not appropriate the Supreme Leader of
Iran is one who ultimately is
responsible for the hostile conduct of
the regime he's respected within this
country his office oversees the regime's
most brutal instruments including the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard for
sanctions imposed through the executive
order that I'm about to sign will deny
the Supreme Leader and the Supreme
Leader's office and those closely
affiliated with him and the office
access to key financial resources in
support the assets of Ayatollah Khomeini
and his office will not be spared from
the sanctions these measures represent a
strong and proportionate response to
Iran's increasingly provocative actions
we will continue to increase pressure on
terror until the regime abandons its
dangerous activities and aspirations
including the pursuit of nuclear weapons
increased enrichment of uranium
development of ballistic missiles
engagement in and support for terrorism
fuelling of foreign conflicts and
belligerent acts directed against the
United States and its allies
the agreement that was signed was a
disaster he's not doing what I was
supposed to do many bad things were
taking place and most importantly it was
so short-term that within a very short
number of years they would be able to
make nuclear weapons and that's
unacceptable
never can Iran have a nuclear weapon
also included in this is we want the
stoppage immediately of this sponsoring
of terrorism they sponsor terrorism at
the level that nobody's ever seen before
and that's been over the last number of
years and they've taken all of that
money that was given to them by the past
administration and much of it was given
out to terrorist organizations in fact I
remember when John Kerry was asked the
question about whether or not this money
will be spent for terror he actually
said yes or at least he was referring to
some of it but he said yes it was it
will be useful if you could believe that
we give it a money we're saying yes it
can be used for terror that was not a
good answer but that was the least of it
frankly so America is a peace-loving
nation we do not seek conflict with Iran
or any other country I look forward to
the day when sanctions can be finally
lifted and Iran can become a peaceful
prosperous and productive nation that
can go very quickly it can be tomorrow
it could also be in years from now so I
look forward to discussing whatever I
have to discuss with anybody that wants
to speak in the meantime who knows
what's going to happen I can only tell
you we cannot ever let Iran have a
nuclear weapon and won't happen and
secondly and very importantly we don't
want money going out to sponsor terror
they are the number one sponsor
the world so outside disorder right now
and I want to thank our military I want
to thank all of the people that have
been working with me over the last
number of months on this there's a lot
of restraint has been shown by us a lot
of restraint and that doesn't mean we're
going to show it in the future but I
felt that we want to give this a chance
give it a good chance because I think
Iran potentially has a phenomenal future
just and I say that about North Korea
too
I've said it about North Korea I think
he is a phenomenal future and I think
Iran also has a phenomenal future and it
would like to I think a lot of people
would like to see them get to work on
that great future so I'll sign this now
and I appreciate you all being here
thank you
[Music]
we would love to be able to negotiate a
deal if they want to if they don't want
to that's fine too but we would love to
be able to and frankly they might as
well do it soon
but obviously the people of around are
great people you know many of them I
lived in New York I've been there very
much the last two and a half years but I
know many Iranians living in New York
and there are fantastic people I have
many friends that are Iranian and it's
just very sad what's happening to that
country the deal should have never been
done it wasn't ratified by Congress
wasn't properly done as you know as a
treaty it wasn't properly done it was
incorrectly done but we'll get it
properly done so we'll see what happens
I hope it's gonna be for the good but
the people you know ran a great people
and all of the people I know so many of
New Yorkers and great people anything
else this you could probably Steve add
that into it but basically this is
something that was going to happen
anyway
I won't say what I'll do but I don't
think they should do Ghent my only
message is this is the potential to have
a great country and quickly very quickly
and I think they should do that rather
than going along this we discuss the
path destructive for everybody
destructive for everybody we can't let
him have a nuclear weapon he said he
doesn't want nuclear weapons great thing
to say but a lot of things have been
said over the years and turns out to be
not so but he said very openly and
plainly for everyone to hear he does
want to have so if that's the case we
can do something